hello everyone this is Ami here from
audio science review this uh follow-up
to my uh video that I just posted
yesterday on how to read the speaker
measurements I promise that I would show
you a couple of more examples so that
you get better used to uh
um looking at speakers with different
levels of performance
um to start I'm going to cover this uh
speaker from company German company
called Neumann
kh150 it's a studio monitor meaning that
it has uh active crossover and
amplification in there so what you feed
to this is is line level inputs you see
the RCA input in here or you can feed it
balanced input this is a DSP speaker
means that it has signal processing in
inside and is able to apply filtering to
the response of the speaker
all of that is detailed that you don't
need to worry about the proof of the
pudding is how well it performs
so let's get into our measurements
as I mentioned in the last video I used
a clip old near field scanner to
generate anechoic response and uh
look at the on-axis response unless the
first thing we look at which is this
black line in here look at how perfect
this is I mean it doesn't get better
than this this is a speaker with all the
variability that comes in in having a
speaker and the drivers and so forth but
look at how linear and and flat the
response is
it doesn't get any better than that and
so as far as our on-axis performance is
concerned it's perfect
our early window which is those summary
of of the strongest Reflections has a
little bit of a kink in here but not
much you know it's basically you know
this area you can see it mimics this one
and there's a bit of a sloping down in
here but otherwise this is extremely
good what is also extremely good is that
despite the small size of the speaker
look at the low frequency response
there's this nomenclature called F3 or
F6 or F10 that you may hear F3 means if
you go 3db lower than the average what
would that frequency be so we go 3D B in
here we get down to 39 Hertz and if we
go 60 be lower you get down to 35 Hertz
so it's to have a two-way speaker that's
compact that sits on your desk and you
can see the comparison size to my
figurine over here uh it's not that big
of a speaker but it's able to go
extremely low in in frequency so that's
quite impressive and look how flat is
low frequency responses
um I get a question sometimes people
saying what is this crippled stuff you
should really use on echoic chamber and
that's really the perfect thing there is
and and they don't understand all the
explanation that I gave them why this
clipple system is able to generate that
kind of thing but this is a very good
proof Point uh Neumann is one of the few
Pro companies that actually measures
each speaker and not only do they
measure each speaker that comes out of
the factory but also store and remember
the exact frequency response of that
speaker so when I got the kh120 and I
measured it I gave my measurement back
to Neumann and they overlay the two
together so the green is is the one that
I measured and the Orange is what they
had measured in their anechoic chamber
and as you can see the two graphs land
right on top of each other indicating
that both of our measurements are
extremely accurate and and this is not
the first time this happened I've done
this testing multiple times with them
and also with the genelec which is the
other company that's that does this kind
of thing and so this should be a very
good proof point that uh you know the
measurement system I have is is as good
as as an echoic chamber
okay so with that out of the way then we
look at the early Reflections remember
early Reflections are the off-axis
response of the speaker as it hits the
walls and ceiling and floor and the
labels are up here they sum to this uh
what we call Total early Reflections and
you can if I draw a trend line in here
we just see a small dip in here that
small dip happens because of the
vertical performance of a speaker if you
recall I said that if you have a two-way
speaker because of the distance between
a woofer and Twitter at some frequencies
the two don't sum anymore and they start
to cancel each other so you get a slight
amount of dip in here this is actually
quite mild for a two-way speaker and you
can see that it's vertical is that's the
problem because this red one is a
ceiling bounce you can see that causes
the largest dip over here and the next
largest step is actually the floor
bounce so it's the vertical response
that's got deficiency in there but the
horizontally we have very good response
on this thing indeed they if you look at
this little orange line that's faded
over here you can see it's ruler flat
and that's the sound that's that's
hitting uh behind you in front of the
speaker so if you want to be very anal
about this you want to avoid floor and
ceiling reflection certainly ceiling one
you could try to put absorbers on the
ceiling or design your room if you can
you're building a studio make sure the
ceiling Heights quite High relative to
where the speakers positioned so that by
the time the reflection comes back from
the ceiling it's quite a bit weakened
compared to what this uses as a model
if we combine our early window with our
on-axis performance and a quick we can
get a predictive response that basically
looks perfect other than this slight dip
that we've already talked about
now this modeling that goes into this is
designed for a home listening spaces
it's not as accurate for near a field
which is what studio monitor will be
used for near field meaning it gets put
on a desk and you listen to it at two or
three meters or you know five to six
feet and but still uh we can see a
speaker that that is designed well also
performs well you know even in in far
field situations so uh if this speaker
fits your needs I would highly recommend
you looking at it as your Hi-Fi speaker
as well
um but you know we can see the power of
of this estimated interim response it
gives us confidence and basically says
the tonality of the speakers extremely
neutral with maybe a slight amount of
recess uh response around one to two
kilohertz
if I uh stick a microphone very close to
the two drivers in the port we can see
some interesting things in here one is
that this port in here and look at how
smoothly it tailors off it has a tiniest
bit of resonance but it continues to go
down without any massive peaks in here
that would interfere with the response
of the woofer and likewise the woofer
itself drops like a rock and you can see
a bad resonance from the woofer but its
level is way way down from where the
Twitter is responding so this does not
interfere with the with the Twitter
response again in a war speaker that's
not well implemented these Peaks could
be here and they could actually come up
and compete with the response or Twitter
means the two get added up and you get
the choppy response in here but it's
extremely well designed speaker
an area that was very surprising to me
was level of distortion in this speaker
this is again small speakers you know
Compact and you don't expect it to be
able to produce base with low Distortion
but look at what it's doing you know
I've got this 50 DB threshold and uh
it's well below that normally I only see
this in large Tower speakers we have
multiple drivers and high efficiency uh
four or five times the size of this
speaker and look at you know and they
get this kind of distortion look at how
good this Associates look at the amount
of white space which is what you want to
see Distortion basically sinks down to
nothing in here it's just amazing see
who fall in love the chart at the bottom
in here and even when we go to 96 DB SPL
across bulk of the audible range this is
well below the 50 DB and here just
barely starts to get above the uh my
reference line in here again we never
see this in in two-way speakers uh
Neumann tells me to spend two years
worth working on this driver that one
the woofer and here trying to get the
Distortion down some people talk about
you know have we learned anything in
design of speakers in the last 10 20 30
40 years and the answers definitely yes
when it comes to Distortion they're
extremely good tools available for both
modeling and simulation and also design
optimization prototyping that allows
Engineers to really really start a
lowered amount of distortion that the uh
speaker generates we can see it also
this is the same measurement as that one
it's just a percentage of distortion
rather than absolute level and you can
see it just hugs the zero line over here
and even at 96 DB is hugging the zero
line in here so it's just amazing
amazing performance uh it just my eyes
didn't believe looking at these charts
next we look at the directivity see how
wide the response of the speaker is and
how smooth it is we see that the
directive it is very controlled it just
gradually gets a little smaller so we
have 50 plus or minus 50 degrees at each
end up to about three kilohertz and then
it sort of goes to 40 degrees or so but
it's still very very well controlled
it's very smooth it you're basically
losing a little bit of high frequency
the farther you go to the left and right
but the bulk of the response will not
change so what this means that the
tonality of the speaker is similar
whether you go you know one foot to the
left or right in front of your mixing
desk or what have you and these other
lines above which I don't usually talk
about but look at how predictable they
are these are just higher amount of
um uh amplitude that we allow to drop
look how similar they are and how well
behaved this is and same graph plotted
as a heat map you can see the beautiful
smooth graph in here just you know with
without any you know lots of spikes and
other kinds of anomalies
but in a two-way design is a two-way
design and uh
if you go above a few degrees this is
about 20 plus or minus 20 degrees you
land in these eyes which is the what I
talked about the floor and ceiling
Reflections so you do want to put this
speaker so that the Toyota actually the
reference point is slightly below the
Twitter the company uh
um documents that so you want to keep
that reference design which is a little
bit below the Twitter at your ear level
so either elevated to your ear level or
pointed up to your ear level uh to avoid
being inside these dolls luckily your
height doesn't change as you listen to
music you may go left or right but you
rarely go up and down so it's not a big
limitations
I talked about before how the you know
the uh waterfall or CST plot doesn't
show you much and it doesn't other than
we see one little resonance in here that
that around two kilos or so is a tiny
one this little pesky one in here
um I don't care about the sub response
if you do hear this
and on this thing so
um the next was a listening test
um you look in here and the first thing
you notice is that there's no EQ
graph in here because I didn't need to
equalize it I'll have a standard set of
reference tracks which I probably should
do a video on and explain them and as
soon as I play the first frog I've
played that track probably five or seven
hundred times I've just listened to it
multiple times with every speaker and
that's that sound that is quite familiar
to me of just this neutral Fidelity and
it just came out but what was amazing
also with this speaker was just the base
extension has the amount of power
handling I just did not expect to hear
that kind of performance coming out of a
little compact speaker
sitting on on my desk uh it just you
know you just want to listen to it and
and your eyes just can't believe that
this Fidelity and performance and bass
extension is all coming out of the
speaker
so needless to say uh it got very high
ratings um one thing I didn't talk about
in the last video in that every one of
the uh my speaker reviews come with an
export in a text CSV file that actually
exports both horizontal and vertical
response or about 70 measurements that
give you every 10 degrees in both
vertical and horizontal the full data is
exported and members take this and I
think there is one coming out is there
the report uh
sorry I didn't look in advance to see if
the preference scores are up but members
take these things and generate
preference scores and then generate EQ
for it but everything that I do it
contributes to open source knowledge of
of speakers so the I don't know 300 of
the speakers that I've measured all 300
of them have uh exported uh frequency
response in full 3d space not just on
access not just one graph but a complete
Globe around the speaker in every 10
degree increments which is what the
standard calls for
okay so this was a great example and
really you know you could just tell this
great by just looking at the first graph
you know when the on axis is that clean
you know it already told you how great
it was and the next thing is really
Distortion and when you see graphs are
this cleaning you'll love it
um for the next example of some speaker
uh I was just watching uh a reviewer
um audiophiliac and somebody asked them
in the last talk he gave was uh what is
his sort of uh end game system is and he
said this this Klipsch RPM 60m RP 1600 m
is is uh sort of like you know last
speaker that I need to own and and I'll
be done kind of thing I was quite
surprised if you've sort of decoded my
code for uh these figurines is that the
uh for European speakers there are
European audio products I use the soccer
one and for rest of the world I use a
golfing Panther from there they were
great uh but when something is really
the exact opposite they get this
headless Panther and his arm broken it
actually used to have a head but it fell
down and its head broke and I thought I
use it uh for to indicate that on bike
something uh because basically says a
broken design and indeed this is broken
and I think it's broken by Design
um but anyway
um since he said that was his his uh you
know greatest speaker that you know
matter of his greatest thing is heard
but he certainly wanted to speak her to
to uh to live with forever and actually
quoted some uh
um the reviews over here saying how
great the vocals were the voices were
vibrantly present in the room and this
will be interestingly around to see if
that claim is this is a subjective uh
audio file uh reviewer in in
stereophiles saying these things uh but
you know the measurement section
actually said there was a slightly lack
of energy in a crossover region we'll
see how true that is what this really
was slightly less energy in a crossover
region that's never a good thing because
the crossover region is really in the
most critical region of of the uh
um uh musical you know uh Spectrum so we
you know we don't want any depression in
there but anyway
let's jump into that and see what our
own access response looks like uh
immediately we see a giant problem in
here right if you look and you know I
mean you can't miss it yeah we have also
some other problems within here where we
have some uh you know peaking over here
then we have a base that sort of droops
and then goes down it's kind of okay
because the room will impact this but
you know what on Earth is going on in
here why do we have to suck out you know
right at two kilohertz really we want to
lose this much energy out of our music
everything you listen to every music you
listen to whoever created it for you
which likely used Neumann or general Egg
or some Pro monitor that a flat response
and you think you want to second guess
every artist and every producer and
every engineer that you know no I want
to take a you know big bite out of one
Killers to three killers in the middle
in here well the speaker doesn't stop in
here and the clips to you know famous
for having boosted highs will we call a
showroom sound that and so we can see
the highs are peaking and by time you
get to 20 kilohertz you know you were on
another four or five DB higher in here
and uh so what does this do it takes out
this energy and then it brightens the
sound at the same time
um since the bass is also depressed in
here this brightness is even more
pronounced than it would be otherwise if
we add more bass in here to complement
it so clearly this is not right I don't
think this is an accident you don't
design a speaker like this by accident I
think Clips designers know this and
probably the marketing department or
somebody forced them to to design the
speaker there's such a broken matter
but we can go on and jump to the uh
estimated in-room response and it says
what we already could have predicted
which is boy you're gonna have a massive
suck out in here and potentially a
little bright uh one thing on
sensitivity active speakers you know
have their own amplifiers and we don't
get exposed to the uh on drivers
themselves but with a passive speaker
like this Klipsch the system actually
spits out how sensitive it is and uh
unfortunately the uh there is no
accepted uh number for sensitivity in
speakers even though every speaker
manufacturer practically advertises one
for that reason they're all garbage
numbers you can essentially ignore them
and that that's what happens in here
with Klipsch I think they expect this at
93 or some crazy 93 DB SPL one meter
likely they're taking the value from way
to heck up here sure a second guard not
like taking it down here we're stopping
down to 83 DB and I know by the way the
best sensitivity you care about is in
base that's where it takes a lot of
amplification power to spit out sound
that's the Sensitivity I care about not
what it does it way up here where it's
so easy to drive because there's not
much there so you can see this wide
range of sensitivity numbers so I don't
always document the sensitivity number
but you can see it the frequency
response is the sensitivity generally
speaking if you want one number you
average everything from here to here you
know this middle region and whatever the
average value is becomes your
sensitivity in this case uh you'll be
about 88 DB or so most typical numbers
86 DB 85 to 86 DB I'd say about 60 70
percent of the speakers that I review
are around 86 DB which is not very
efficient but it's not very sensitive
you need a fair amount of power but once
you go above 90 things are good
so anyway
um this speaker actually has very good
directivity because if you go back it
actually has you know a wave guide in
here you sort of can't see it but this
is a deep they call it a horn but
probably closer to a waveguide than a
than a horn it's sort of halfway between
them and because of that it is able to
control the beam width of the Twitter
and match it with the woofer and uh
because of that you know for good or bad
we see that this early window response
is actually very close to on axis right
so and we can see proof of that in here
we have this dipping on axis but we also
have an early window look at the tube
match perfect and it's called sound
power all three of them match each other
perfectly what that means is that we can
equalize this without fear because when
we fix their own axis we pull this up
the off axis also comes up with it and
we actually get to fix everything at
once so this is actually a very easy
problem to fix and I'll talk about it in
a minute so as far as door activity it
actually does well but in this case we
don't want it to do well because the
offer axis also has this suck out in
energy which which we don't want
okay another thing I'll do with passive
speakers that obviously doesn't apply to
active speakers that are measured
there's impedance and phase and I
document the lowest impedance uh in this
case lowest impedance at 200 Hertz and
about 3.2 ohm that's fairly typical uh
you usually get 3.5 3.6 ohm as the worst
case around 200 Hertz and uh but if you
look at the speaker manufacturer I think
that they expect is at 8 ohm that's just
fantasy yes it's eight home at some
higher frequency but we care about base
as far as the impedance and here we say
3.5 here or 3.2 here which is fairly low
and then 3.5 or 4 ohm at 50 hertz so
forget about the fantasy of this being
at home if you want one number to use
for all your speakers is really Forum
don't ever think you have an eight ohm
unless somebody shows it to you but
obviously there's no one number you know
at every frequency you know the
impedance is changing going way up here
and going way down but most of the
energy in music is in low frequencies so
we care about the impedance in here I
won't get into the phase for now but the
phase will determine how difficult
um this uh this this number really is
the effective value may actually be
lower than it seems
okay but I always document this so in
this case you know you have almost a
three home uh uh uh speakers you better
have a stout amplifier with good power
capability don't don't think you could
just hook up a little Tube app at Steve
was doing and audiophiliac was saying in
his video he has a little I think it was
a set amplifiers or something which
those things put up very little power
and saying that was the ideal pairing
for this which uh boggles my mind but uh
uh if he likes it I guess he likes it uh
on this thing anyway
um this was uh measured a while ago
before I standardized things with
showing you uh two outputs at you know
86 and 96 DB SPL so apologize for that
but we do see Joseph looking at the
relative Distortion we can see that
um the woofers getting unhappy the
Twitter is actually doing well Twitter's
you know not getting too unhappy but the
woofer is generating uh distortions out
here and that's not a good thing because
it gets very close to our hearing is is
very sensitive but overall it's not too
bad
um I talked about how we don't care
about the CSD waterfall and this early
displays I hadn't optimized them as well
but I did explain in the last video how
easy it is to change the parameters and
get completely different looking
describes and look how different this is
from previous versions of this I showed
you
um these two graphs uh don't work as
well as manure ones because of that dip
that we had in mid-range it really shows
this to be uh potentially worse than it
is but uh so I'm not going to drill too
much but obviously we can look at this
thing and and just see what the width is
so it's not giving us much width about
40 degrees which is a little narrow and
vertically you better stay right at the
Tweeter Axis or you have more problems
with with dips in this area
okay
so how did I fix this
um
uh pretty easy uh the major fixes is
basically to put this uh
um compensation filter in here well I'm
just boosting these frequencies up and
then I also to bring the highs down I
just put a lazy filter of just rolling
off the highs you could sit there and
build a you know fancier shelving filter
or something and uh on this thing so I
also have a room mode in here and I'm
compensated for that so sometimes the
eqs that I put in here is because of my
room it isn't because of the speaker
itself so really the heart of this is
this one uh uh compensation that you
need in here and if the company had paid
better attention or or wanted to build a
flat response all they had to do was
bring the two the crossover frequencies
together uh sooner rather than you know
later in that so they allowed a dip in
the middle
um what's amazing is that as soon as you
turn this on the speaker transforms and
and it becomes a wonderful sounding
speaker without her this bride and just
sounds non-hi-fi to me I mean you suck
out the life out of the uh music in this
region this is like upper mid range Lord
treble where there's just a lot of I
find you know what sounds great in
music's actually buried in here and you
recess that it just sounds odd but put
that back in and all of a sudden the
speaker's really really singing and
indeed you know I sat there and I just
you know listened to track after
tracking the track it becomes that good
and that sort of tells you the power of
Equalization where we can take a faulty
design like this and and compensate you
know ideally we wouldn't have to become
a speaker designer and fix it but that's
what measurements allow you to do in
that we can first fix the speaker and
then we can also look at fixing the room
response which is what I did quickly in
in here okay so to me there's no better
proof in here we have objective proof
that says hey lucky don't want to add
this kind of coloration to to you all
everything you play you have a you know
just a suck out in here just makes no
sense to be doing that and and that's
the pearls of of listening to a you know
subjective reviewer or just turns on
speaker and maybe is our ears tuned to
this high resolution exaggeration he
also used a tube amp and those two Vamps
have high impedance and that impedance
of the tubes is uh amplifier interacts
with this variable uh impedance and will
actually change the effective frequency
response that you see in here so the
poor speaker has one response here if
you drove it properly with a amplifier
that doesn't have its own high impedance
hook it up to a tube amp that has a
let's say output Transformer it has x
amount of impedance that will actually
cause exaggeration of this response it
will not fix this hole
so one word the other the hole was there
but he may have boosted the base it may
have reduced the treble or made it even
brighter so we really have a great case
study in here why subjective uh
listening tests are just not valuable
when it comes to speakers they're
complex animals you can't say oh gosh
you know I'm so good in walking water
and I can just listen to a speaker and
say it's great well somebody like me
comes around and shows you this problem
obviously if you don't believe me you
can go to stereophile and see John
Atkinson also tell you that save suck
out of course you know he doesn't want
to upset the uh the Apple cartoon much
and it just you know soft pedals it a
little bits and a slight lack of energy
in crossover region no there wasn't a
slight lack of energy it was a big time
lack of energy uh on this thing so
um you cannot see the power of
measurements in telling you you know
when you have a superb speaker this is
what you want to see there's no suck out
in here there's no exaggeration in here
and by the way if you like different
tonality use Equalization I can take
this and give it more bass I can bring
you the treble down I like do whatever I
can make it sound like the uh Club
speaker but wouldn't suck out in here uh
but you know out of box is designed to
tell you the truth what is on your
recording that is a truth comes out so
that is a given now he's all right now
you know what the speaker music's
supposed to sound like but maybe I will
preference a little bit more bass a
little bit less highs what have you and
you overlay what we call a Target curve
on top of this and and to taste but you
don't get you know caught up in having a
speaker like this and you think this is
correct sound and then one day it goes
somebody's house and you hear this you
say whoa I didn't know what I was
missing all this time well you know look
at the measurements measurements are
powerful like this and in this case it's
really really a simple case of you know
what is wrong in here and and we can see
glaring fault and by the way we can fix
it we just apply some simple
organization and you turn this really
crappy sounding speaker to a very very
nice speaker
okay hopefully uh you learned something
out of this I'll be doing more future
speaker review videos and go over these
things again but I'm hoping with these
two examples and the one in the last
video that you're coming up to speed and
getting good muscle memory of how to
read these uh speaker measures okay see
you in a future video bye-bye